the thing we want to do is kick off
another theme week
and it's beauty week that's right
i am a beauty junkie and today
and all week long we're going to be
celebrating all things beauty both
inside and out
and i feel as strongly about serums and
scrubs as i do about
stains and if you've ever seen the show
you know that's a lot of passion
that's right in all seriousness i have
been working in the beauty industry well
almost my whole basically my whole life
i grew up in a makeup chair and
when i was a kid i'd see the women come
in they didn't really do makeup and hair
on me you know they put pigtails on me
and like
you know did the little buff around my
face to make me feel special but
really i would watch these other women
come in and it was like being in the
backstage of ballet
it was magic i'd watch women transform
themselves through hair and makeup
and i saw their body language change and
their confidence levels skyrocket
and we need these little tools in our
arsenal
but i do really believe that beauty
comes from within
and if you don't have the right internal
mindset
i believe emphatically that you will be
hindered from looking your best on the
outside
but sometimes we need a little help and
a little zhu zhing and that's where
beauty tools come in
and gosh do i know about that working
with flower beauty for 10 years being a
cover girl
for many years before that this industry
is important and meaningful to women
and we just always have to get the
messaging right so
we're gonna do so many things today the
roster of guests we have
really blows my mind i'm just beyond
excited for
today and this week and we're gonna
start and kick it off and have some fun
we're gonna have this beautiful woman
get ready with us and go from a to z
because she's here right now her name is
jessica walter
hi jessica hi thank you so much for
having me
oh thank you so much it's an honor for
me too
all right so you are a frontline
essential superhero
and you want to get ready because i
believe something happened in your life
recently
oh it sure did what is that so
i'm an essential worker at the hospital
and i need to get ready for a virtual
date and i have no idea what to wear i
don't know what to wear i don't know
what to do with my hair or my makeup and
that's where you come in so i'm going to
need your help
okay i am like your little mascot we
have a team of people we're going to
help like but really we just want to
watch your process and engage with you
throughout the show so
let's remove your mask okay
okay yeah you're stunning oh my god and
not as pretty as you i love your curly
hair
you want to go with a more barrel rolled
look that's your comfort zone yes
it is if that's totally cool with you
it's totally fine with me it's just
ironic because we always want what we
don't have
straight hair you want curly you got
curly hair you want straight okay so
let's start with your hair and then
i'm gonna pick out a little foundation
for you
thank you that's right and then i'm also
going to
grab this because it's my favorite do
you prefer a powder or a gel blush
let's go for powder today okay then
these actually
um i'm gonna prefer this one these
actually won um an allure
best in beauty award i'm proud to say i
know i'm so excited
so much and all right let's start with
that and then i want to see where you go
with that
and then pick your lip according to your
outfit jessica will be doing the show
thank you so much excited
i'm such a romantic literally my wing
woman okay i am your wing woman
we're in the midst of a get ready with
jessica
who is an essential frontline worker and
totally beautiful
and has a virtual date
how's it going oh it's going you're
working that
progress okay all right next is makeup
jessica how are you doing
good how are you i'm great it's time for
your lip you chose the honey nude
i did all right are you rocking it maybe
a little blush now
okay we'll check in with you at the end
of the show it's it's happening
we have been uh all so long working with
jessica
oh who's not here she's coming from the
double yellow door she is here
jessica come through oh my god
oh my gosh i looked over and i'm like
she's not there but there she is okay
xana and i want to ask
what are you most excited about for your
date this outfit
this hair and your products that i used
on my face i mean
thank you so much and i'm so excited to
finally meet him virtually
uh you chose the right lipstick because
you look gorgeous
thank you so much beautiful thank you i
need to know where that cardigan is and
what is one thing that like his profile
said or getting to know him or setting
up the date really spoke to you out of
curiosity
so he um he just seems really genuine
and i love that in a man
somebody who's gonna you know show up
for a date
virtually like that's a lot of work i
mean you know it's a pandemic
so well you really should show up with
all the confidence in the world because
you
are doing important things in this world
you're a good selfless
human and you're also stunning so i
hope you show up knowing you have so
much to offer thank you so much drew
that means so much to me
well it's true and as anna and i really
believe in this world
the way that you feel on the inside is
truly reflective of how you will be on
the outside
you